[Music]
[Applause]
uh Nate Atkins uh Colts Insider for the
Indianapolis Star had a lot of really
good things talking about the 10
thoughts on Jonathan Taylor's contract
standoff with the Colts and Nate joins
us from Colts Camp all right give us the
uh sort of Cliff Notes version here Nate
how did we get to this point with
Jonathan Taylor and Jim ersek
man this has been something that's been
building really since last season ended
Jonathan Taylor coming off of a high
ankle sprain needed ankle surgery got it
in January and then was entering you
know a contract year and he felt at the
time that he was going to be able to
just kind of play it the way he's always
played it which is nice guy team you
know team player all of that this team
is rewarded player after player heading
into their contract year whether it's
Quentin Nelson Shaquille Leonard Braden
Smith on and on and then when he got to
somewhere around May realized that the
offers weren't coming the Colts were
kind of in a new place with Shane
steichen they wanted to let some things
play out they wanted to see how his
health was going to be so he switched up
switched up agents and ever since that
moment it's just kind of ramped up to
where the offer is not coming training
camp arriving the threat of having to
practice and risk that more injury
without security just got him in a place
where he didn't really know what to do
and so it just really ramped up to the
point where they met on a bust Jonathan
Taylor and Jim Mercy uh just uh was that
two days ago and met for an hour and
realized that they were not anywhere
close together and that's when it came
out that he's requested a trade and and
Jim Murphy talked to us and many other
outlets and said we're not trading him
and so this has become just an ultimate
stare down of uh two sides that just
flat out don't trust each other but
there's not really a clear resolution
because the Colts value him enough to
want him to be here for Anthony
Richardson help him support him for this
year but not promise anything beyond
that and not promise a negotiation until
after the season ends which is obviously
not what Jonathan Taylor wants okay yeah
Jonathan Taylor's switch agent saquon
Barkley switched agents what are they
hoping to get from the new agents that
they didn't get from the old agents as
far as getting more money
it's really just a new negotiating
tactic like I said last Jonathan's grown
up here in the Colts the past three
years where just just a year ago at this
time Quentin Nelson was in the exact
same spot and the Colts when we talked
to Chris Ballard said you know I'm not
going to talk contracts but Quentin
Nelson's a cult it's going to happen and
then the night before the season he gets
60 million dollars guaranteed in the
biggest contract in the history of
football for a guard and so Jonathan
thought as the you know it was the clear
best player in that offense back in at
least 2021 when he won the rushing title
I think he just thought it was a
formality and the fact that it got so
long into you know into almost June and
realized he's not he hasn't even gotten
a single offer not even a lowball offer
from them it just was so out of
character with what he'd seen so far and
he just decided you know I don't know
what else to do he's trying to get ahead
of it right as the running back Market
is crumbling it's it's not you know he's
just not sure what cars to play so he
decided to kind of move it to a nuclear
level and the Colts really didn't give
him any other options because they
didn't make a low ball offer that he
could even say okay I can take some kind
of offer that's out there to him no
offer just means no options uh tell me
what Jim Murray say is saying in this
sound bite
if I die tonight and Jonathan tears out
of the league No One's Gonna Miss us the
league goes on I mean you know we know
that the National Football rolls on it
doesn't matter you know who who comes
and who goes where'd this come from
I'd actually ask that question to to Jim
Murphy not on that topic I was just
trying to get him to to open up on the
debriefing meeting on the bus and as
best I can tell I think his message to
Jonathan is just like you need to you
need to realize the spot you're in the
opportunity you have to go out there and
build something Dynamic with Anthony
Richardson and the the message he's
trying to put out there is if you bet on
yourself have a big year in a contract
year then it'll all work out but you
understand why in this current you know
state of the running bike Market why
Jonathan's not listening to that
especially when there's that franchise
tag lingering out there that teams use
all the time on running backs there
isn't this there's no pot of gold at the
end of the rainbow right now for running
backs the pot of gold is a franchise tag
that was initially designed as a window
to get a long-term deal done instead
what it looks like to running backs is a
way to just rent them run up the mileage
on their carries and their health and
then set them in a free agency as some
lower version of themselves so it's a
messenger say thought he could get
through of like come on Beat team player
get on board with this thing and
Jonathan's like Okay show it through
some kind of action but
um we're talking to Nate Adkins he
covers the Colts for the Indianapolis
Star the more I thought about it it's
personal for the player it's business
for the owner but here is an owner who
inherited a team Jonathan Taylor is
working for his money Jim Murphy got his
money he was given his money he woke up
on third base and I'm sure he's done
things to enhance the value and all that
but Jonathan Taylor is going this is my
livelihood here so the disconnect may be
how each other views one another he's
business this is personal and they've
maintained those battle lines
oh it's absolutely that and that's why
that comment I think has gotten so much
you know dialogue is that to compare the
privilege of an NFL owner to a running
back right now is is just kind of very
out of line you know like of course you
know in that analogy yes Jim Mercy could
die tomorrow but there's not a real
present threat that could have him out
of his position in this league in two
years whereas for Jonathan Taylor you
know another couple injuries serious
injuries and that's exactly what he's
facing and he will have not you know he
doesn't have the generational wealth to
fall back on whereas if Jim irsay if he
decided you know if for some reason he
got edged out at being an owner he's
still got he's still set up financially
for life so there's his kids and his
grandkids Jonathan just got married this
you know this past spring so he's
wondering when do I get even anything
that looks remotely like that privilege
that you're talking about and that's why
the disconnect just keeps on growing
good to talk to you Nate thanks we'll be
following we appreciate your time yeah
thanks for having me Nate Adkins covers
the cold for the Indianapolis Star